- [Ann] Vladimir Putin's private life,
or the wealth he owns,
are closely guarded secrets.
As the war in Ukraine continues,
this has made it a challenge
for the US and Western allies
to target Putin and his inner circle,
directly with sanctions,
but that hasn't stopped them
from trying to impose them on
him and two of his daughters.
- President Putin and Russian oligarchs
stash assets and resources
in the bank accounts
of their family members.
And so this was an effort
to get at those assets.
- Here's what we know about
the Russian president's family
and their assets.
Unlike Western leaders,
Putin doesn't usually appear in public
with his family members.
Images like this one, from state media,
showing Putin on holiday
with his family in 2002,
are rare.
In April, US officials
identified Katerina Tikhonova
and Maria Vorontsova, as his daughters.
They say one is a tech executive
and the other works in genetics research.
Both are his daughters from
his former wife, Lyudmila,
according to the Kremlin.
Putin doesn't discuss them publicly,
and they keep such a low profile
that many in Russia don't
even know what they look like.
We also don't know whether
Putin has other children
or a partner.
Putin avoids talking about his
family for security reasons,
according to Russia's
state news agency, TASS.
And what about Putin's assets
that Western officials say he's
hiding with family members?
How much is Russia's president worth
and where is his wealth?
Putin declared a salary
of about $130,000 in 2020,
but his critics and political opponents
have long said his wealth
is, in effect, much greater,
because of the level of control and power
he has in the country.
(classical violin music)